nearly four weeks after the Florida
school massacre the White House is
officially announcing which changes in
gun policy it will support the list does
not include raising the age limit for
some gun buyers to 21 but it does call
for arming specially trained teachers
and focusing more on mental health
issues major Garrett is at the White
House Forrest major good morning good
morning president Trump's initial
willingness to consider and even
advocate for some new gun control
measures has evaporated amid NRA
lobbying and resistance from the
republican-led Congress white house
proposals will instead focus on mental
health issues and arming certain school
personnel in general NRA priorities both
the NRA happens to be very good people
by the way they want to do the right
thing at a rally in western Pennsylvania
the president commended the NRA before
unveiling his new proposal we have to
harden our schools not soften another
the president's plan would provide for
quote rigorous firearms training for
some teachers and urges Congress to pass
a bill to make the federal background
check system more effective but the
president is backing off raising federal
agents on rifle purchases like the ar-15
that was used in the Parkland a shooting
takes the guns first go through due
process second however it appears the
president is sticking by an idea he
floated during a bipartisan meeting less
than two weeks ago that would allow
states to pass court orders to remove
guns from people who are threats to go
to court
obtain an order and then collect not
only the firearms but any any weapons in
the position to take the firearms first
and there are a lot of states that are
addressing these issues in very cohesive
and coherent ways Secretary of Education
Betsy DeVos is heading up a new federal
Commission on school violence she spoke
with lesley stahl for 60 minutes do you
feel a sense of urgency yes because this
sounds like talking yeah no there's
avenging there is a sense of urgency
indeed in Washington the best way to
avoid action and dodged a hot political
topic is to create a commission as a
matter of fact over the weekend
President Trump criticized so-called
Blue Ribbon committees as
all talk and immediate aftermath the
parkland shooting the president vowed
action on school safety and gun control
Norah because there there he said at the
time had been simply too much talking
all right
okay reporting their major thank you so
much